It’s easy to be pessimistic about many things:
the state of the planet
the economy
the future of humanity
Yet there’s one area where many of us retain
a curious sense of optimism.
We have faith that, from among the millions
of our fellow human beings out there,
we will one day be able to locate a Very Special
Person, a being uniquely well suited to our
temperatements, tastes and aspirations; someone
who will feel like the missing bit of the
complicated jigsaw of our deep selves - someone
who can make us whole.
We know it won’t be easy to find them. So
many people seem nice, at first, and then the
problems emerge:
it turns out they have a very annoying sister…
or they are far too nervous about things;
always insisting on arriving at the airport
three hours too early…
or they have appalling taste in music…
or their conversation after a long day at
work leaves a lot to be desired.
That’s why we keep searching: calling for
more space, taking a break, getting divorced,
scrolling through future possibilities online…
Though it seems like we must be very romantic
to put such efforts into finding the Right Person
in truth, our perpetual search is
really a refusal of love. It is a guarantee
that we can never succeed at relationships,
because in the end, the deep secret to love
is that there is no Right Person.
There are perfect beings, we can imagine them
very clearly, but - tragically - they exist
only in the upper atmosphere...
...and never down here on the earth…
It’s the insistence on people being Right
that's at the root of rage and intolerance, for
we are never more furious than when we believe
we had signed up to perfection.
And given what the human animal is like, we
can be guaranteed always to find something
that isn’t entirely right.
To be really romantic, truly committed to
what love requires, we need a vital and rarely mentioned quality:
a healthy dose of PESSIMISM
...Pessimism about what even the most perfect-seeming
person will really be like once one gets to know them
and with that pessimism comes forgiveness for the inevitably very
long range of flaws that we’ll discover in them,
and they will - of course - discover in us.
An optimistic search for the Perfect Person
commits us eventually to throwing away everyone
we are ever likely to meet…
Yet in truth, the person who is really best
suited to us is NOT the person who shares
all our tastes, but the person who negotiates
differences in taste intelligently and wisely.
Compatibility is an achievement of love; it
can’t be its precondition.
To be able to love properly, we have to attend
a funeral first: we have to bury a lot of our hopes deep in the ground
That funeral is the most romantic thing we
could ever do. It will liberate us to
go back out into the world and have proper human relationships that can endure, and flourish.